[Music]
this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewers good
afternoon everybody
I'm whisper shouting at you in
excitement because there for the very
first time on Safari live is the new
editions is are the new additions to
this to the Safari Live Club I was going
to say no to the sophistry pride I'm
server whelmed with excitement my name
is James Henry and it's a joy to have
you with us here from the Masai Mara
what we have there are the three
brand-new Cubs of the sausage tree pride
isn't that very special indeed now I'm
not going to get into any of the detail
of what's going on here because what
we're going to do is go to what we call
an unscheduled broadcast so that we can
bring as many people or in the universe
on board as we enjoy this magnificent
sighting of the new Cubs are now going
to shut up
I'm sorry well they're not quite ready
for the unscheduled everybody anyway
I'll tell you that you must ask your
questions of course send them through
the hashtags for life on Twitter
otherwise you can use the YouTube chat
stream I'm sure that all of you are as
overjoyed as I am to be introduced to
these youngsters they were found early
this morning with the other three cubs
who we have yet to see I think they're
around here and we didn't manage to get
down here in the morning but we came
down here now and Peter are superb
Ascari managed to spot them and here we
are sitting with them Kimberly you say
so precious they are beyond precious and
I've always said I think that there are
the cutest things in all the wilderness
they're totally in Congress of course
with the terror of their parents okay
I'm going to shut up now
hello everybody and welcome to the Masai
Mara where we have a tremendously
special treat for you those are three
tiny little Cubs probably only two to
three weeks old and they were on to the
sausage tree pride my name is James
Henry please ask us as many questions as
you'd like to about these fantastic
magnificent little creatures that exist
here in the wilderness that is well very
harsh sometimes utterly adorable at
other times and nothing nothing in the
wilderness personifies that like lions
they are utterly adorable completely
vulnerable at this age and by the same
measure utterly terrifying as adults
totally dominating the plains here of
the Maasai Mara now let's get into the
nuts and bolts of what's going on here
three cubs don't know if they're male or
female yet they are two to three weeks
old we think we're pretty sure they're
around that age and there are the
offspring of a lioness in the sausage
free pride called meaty well that's what
we've called her and she's known that
she's known as that because she climbs
trees they all climb trees but she seems
to like it more than most their father
is one of the old Daniel pi ik males now
I'm told the rest of the pride wandered
off towards the South earlier this
morning
possibly to go hunting we've had no
sight of them we haven't gone looking
very hard I must confess because once we
saw these things we decided to stay
right here
Natalie lion cubs spend a lot of time
alone while their mother is off hunting
these ones of course are too young to
have been introduced to the pride I say
that I suspect the merest of the pride
has probably met them but because the
Brist of the pride
what I mean by let me say that again so
Natalie they're on their own because
their mother's not here with them she's
not here with them because she'll
probably be off
hunting now normally they're introduced
to the prior between four and six weeks
they are however living Denning in the
middle of the sausage tree Pryor
territory so I'm almost certain that the
wrist of the pride has met these little
Cubs but they won't start moving with
the pride until they're at least six
weeks old so for now they're pretty much
in mobile they'll lurk there in that
grass they'll go into the little thicket
to the right of them if they feel
threatened or unsafe they did that when
we arrived and then they came out slowly
in order to investigate us and nataly
that's a great question I think they're
probably a little bit hungry
I suspect quite strongly that they'd
like their mother to arrive fairly soon
to feed them now whether or not she will
I suppose is going to be a waiting game
perhaps as the Sun sets here in the
Maasai Mara methi will return to feed
her babies
[Music]
it's the most gorgeous afternoon all
around us it's a perfect temperature
it's probably about I'm gonna say 25
degrees Celsius 75 degrees Fahrenheit
they're starlings calling in the fig
tree behind us and there's a gentle
breeze coming from the north it's
absolutely magical to be here on a
Sunday afternoon with three brand-new
little Cubs and now they're very tired
I'm sure they're hungry but they have
been moving around a bit and as with all
very young mammals they get tired very
quickly
Bonecrusher Queens a very good question
we found them I'd love to tell you that
I found them through my incredible
skills as a tracker all my incredible
skills as a spotter of animals but we
did have reports of them in this area
because we told somebody that the older
Cubs were here last night so they came
down here spotted these little ones with
the older Cubs and so then we came down
this afternoon and Peter our arranger on
the back of the car who has much better
eyes than I do
managed to spot them and it's fantastic
just to spend some time with them I am
told that the other three cubs are
around here this is where we saw them
last night but we haven't seen them
again today I suspect that they are now
old enough and they've seen vehicles
often enough for them not to be
particularly concerned or curious about
the arrival of a vehicle and so as with
all lions they sleep a huge amount and
they probably just haven't woken up
despite our arrival so they're probably
in the thickets amongst the grass here
vetti with lions it's pretty easy to
remember the little life stages of their
cubs and you do it like this
six-six-six their eyes open at about six
days they're introduced to the pride at
roughly six weeks and they're weaned at
roughly six months obviously there's a
lot of variation especially with the
last two figures for weaning and for
being introduced to the pride but you'll
find that they
in their eyes round about six days old
so these little chaps will not have been
using their peepers for very long just
yet they will in all likelihood have
been using them for around about two
weeks now
many of you wondering are they at risk
and the answer is absolutely they're at
risk they are one of the most vulnerable
creatures in the wilderness it's one of
the reasons one in ten roughly makes it
to adulthood they are defenseless like
they are here they are certainly
vulnerable to any marauding hyena that
might come through here ah hyena will be
careful though because they'll smell
lion in amongst this area and so they'd
be very careful of coming through here
likewise there are leopard in this area
we never male and a female who use this
little riverbed that were parked along
to come they use the hunting and so
certainly even the leopards of this area
could be a real danger to these Cubs
along with strange marauding males if a
buffalo came across them it would
certainly kill them elephants might
damage them big baboons that came
through here would hurt them so yes
they're extremely vulnerable we're gonna
sit here see if the mother comes back I
hope she does as the Sun Goes Down if
you do want to join the risk to the
safari you can do so on YouTube just go
to safari live and you can surf I laugh
on YouTube and you can catch the rest of
the show we'll be here in the Maasai
Mara there are another three people down
at Juma for private game reserve and you
can join us for that into the Safari as
well
so we're just going to let you go as we
enjoy this fantastic sighting
keep rolling keep rolling right
everybody we're gonna wait and see what
happens here let's go back across to
Jamie Patterson well you're gonna
introduce she's gonna introduce herself
to you for the first time this afternoon
hello hello and what a spectacular start
to your Sun set Safari my name is Jamie
and this afternoon Craig is on camera
with me and we are heading out into the
wilds of Africa not in the Masai Mara
you'll notice it looks a little
different where we are but from Jumma
private game reserve which is in the
greater Kruger National Park area of
South Africa and this afternoon we are
going to be searching high and low for
all sorts of things we haven't managed
to be as successful as finding tiny
little lion cubs and this morning
chingada gave us the slip in the brief
switch around where some breakfast was
had he decided to get up and move off to
sleeping the entire morning with Lauren
and Craig he bounced up and off he went
and he's vanished so we've put Steve
well we found some tracks I found some
tracks going towards western side of
quarantine so I've sent Steve in that
direction and I'm just looping the area
where he was just to make sure that we
are not mixing up his tracks with
hassanis tracks but really I'm just
being as thorough as possible for this
afternoon's TV show otherwise we had a
wonderful morning if you missed the
sunrise Safari I had a great time I was
with wild dogs for nearly two hours
which as most of you know is quite an
extended period of time for a wild dog
sighting because they tend to move very
quickly they tend to disappear
and then you really struggle to keep up
with them so it was really quite a
special thing to spend that long with
the Hamiltons pack I enjoyed it
immensely I think they were as still as
they were because of this wind
Jumma is blowing an absolute gale it's a
little bit better now the smoke for this
afternoon it's dropped a little bit but
it really is still incredibly blowy and
what that's done is it's also confused
matters looking at the freshness of
tracks because they're just blown away
sokka - hyena lover wants to know if i
think that we will see hyenas on Drive
today it is definitely possible there's
something but it's not a hyena or a
limpid it is definitely definitely
possible that we could see hyenas I saw
a hyena this morning it was very brief
and right and went running past the wild
dogs but I don't see one so yes it is
entirely possible oh there goes our big
that was a warthog can you see it there
Greg
is it still there cannot a glare is so
fierce I actually can't see I think it
yeah there I can't actually see it in
the gap of the trees there looks like a
male warthog struggling to see that far
definitely potential leopard prey but of
course the warthog can also be very very
dangerous for a leopard even a fully
grown male leopard liked in Ghana I
haven't seen him on a warthog killer in
an extended period of time
I did we did see him try
okie-dokie we're going to continue on
and see if we can catch up with 10 Ghana
and all hisana
and Tristan has found a lovely bird for
you let's go and see which one it is
[Music]
well good after everybody and welcome to
rusty Aniston's before sometime it seems
as though we going to have signal issues
much like we did yesterday which is
going to be a trying afternoon that's
for short my name is Justin on camera
but says Andre once again and hopefully
we will have a better afternoon than we
did yesterday form a number of points of
view one because of signal and two
because of a sighting we had yesterday
that was very very sad which I'll get
into during the course of this afternoon
but actually I suppose we should stop
right now given that time station
because economy yes I can't actually
tell you about anything else
initially we were in Utah yesterday
going down to the dam and we spot a
hippo that was
I'm sorry about that everyone it really
actually is a serious story that Tristan
has to tell you but unfortunately the
gremlins have been playing havoc with
rusty our vehicle for the last few days
it's a long story but unfortunately she
doesn't seem to be doing very well this
afternoon so while tristin tries to sort
that out I'm sure once he's up and
running he will share the story of the
the hippopotamus yesterday I don't feel
that it's my place to finish off his
story I well first of all I wasn't there
and secondly it was very intense very
emotional sighting and I feel that he
has to share it with you properly
fortunately it wasn't one that he was
able to go live with but to be honest it
was there was a great deal of intensity
to that Oh particular sighting so I will
leave that for him to continue once he
manages to battle off the gremlins now
we're on Gary cut line which means we
too could shortly disappear off your
screens but for now we're okay so Emma
just shout when you need me to stop
driving this way I'm just checking to
see husana last night during the
rehearsal managed to lose me in a ditch
he went through the ditch then he went
past the front of our company when went
down towards the dam but he wasn't
picked up on the dam cam which makes me
think that perhaps he crossed a little
bit further to the north or perhaps to
the east and he slunk past somehow
possibly behind dam cam itself actually
none of us up on any tracks but this
morning they spent the morning with the
wild dogs which is great I didn't cover
any ground at all so I've got no updates
on the in coolness it looks like they're
elsewhere because I saw some pictures
going around the various whatsapp group
sans asking about the composition of the
pride
so
I suspect that they are hopefully unite
reunited awesome cool so we will look
for ting garner while sitting still I'll
just go back on myself it's fine it's
not problem ah no I won't I'll carry on
because the good news is is that Steve
is up and running apart from his
peculiar game Drive comes this afternoon
he seems to be able to hear what Emma's
trying to say to him good afternoon
everybody welcome to juma private game
reserve my name is indeed Steve I'm
joined on camera by Sebastian who had a
wonderful birthday yesterday and while
we are out in the African alter the
seeing what we can find
please as I'm sure you've been told
Cynthia questions hashtag Safari love or
throw them in on the YouTube chat stream
let us know what you'd like to see this
afternoon we obviously are trying to
find some of our characters and well who
knows who we're gonna find we're just
going to cover the whole property in
search of ting Ghana I think Jamie's
putting some effort in to see if she can
find him he was left around Galago pan
this morning Lauren to try and follow up
after breakfast to see if she could get
him but he had moved of course it was a
very nice overcast morning nice and
chilly actually so we are now in the
center just trying to see if we can find
any tracks so far it's been a very quiet
afternoon but nonetheless it is going to
be a wonderful day this is a very
popular area the right chap for or sauna
I'm gonna see if we can find him and to
be really nice I'm sure we do have a TV
show this evening he always pops out
just in time but in the meantime just go
over to Tristan who's good a feathered
friend
well we're going to try this all again
and see if rusty is going to behave
itself and not give us so much trouble
and we're going to do that with a
beautiful little bird that is sitting so
elegantly on the edge of twin dams it is
called a barn swallow and there's barn
swallows all over the place yeah and
they landing on this brushing or brush
packed material that's on the dam wall
that's trying to stop erosion on the dam
wall itself and from here they can fly
out and be able to hawk all kinds of
different little insects as well as be
able to drink and they all fly down and
kind of scoop water from the dam itself
and this is a really nice place to kind
of see them most of these ones that
we're seeing here are non breeding
adults funny enough it's quite
interesting because they'll show a brush
brighter coloration when they're
breeding get a much more chestnut kind
of color on the head area and and blues
and a lot of these are quite pale at the
moment so I would imagine inside the
youngsters or non breeding individuals
and that particular one there's a
youngster within the group at the moment
but very very cool to see him trying to
actually see them nicely it's so much
clearer on a little screen that I've got
that I can't actually see too well it
may be that's not even a bonsoir a
difficult does it have watch on his
Andre
now I believe a lot of you are saying
these are beautiful they are very very
pretty little birds and generally we
don't really get clear views of them
because of how fast they fly it's very
difficult for us to be kind of get them
on camera and they normally darting
around far from us but because of the
the sort of proximity of the brush
packing to the water they're actually
sitting really close and so we can get
these really nice views and you can see
how they struggling with the wind this
afternoon it is hauling gale that is
blowing at the moment which is making it
very difficult if you're a bird trying
to balance on a branch like that so
their feathers are designed to kind of
catch wind and so these guys are being
blown about all over the place at the
moment which is nice when they are
flying but when they push not so nice
now Lily's eight years old wants to know
what gives the bird its shiny feathers I
think that's what I got from all of that
all the gloss on this particular bird
and you probably find that there's a
couple of things there so one is
feathers themselves contain certain
pigments within them so types of cells
that are able to reflect light a little
bit the other thing is is that they all
have preening oils that will come out of
their skin that will often be brushed
through that feathery
area and that gives them a little bit
more of a glisten but most of it is to
do with pigments and so the way that the
light is hitting those cells and coming
back at our eye is cool using that
iridescent kind of gloss to come back at
us it's the same as things like
starlings
that kind of shiny appearance that
they've got is often due to that reason
very cute little birds but now just now
telling you about our sad story and so
I'm gonna use this opportunity given
that we've got signal which is going to
be a rarity at this rate so we went to
check for damage Andre and I and we were
sulking at our signal issues and we
hadn't found our lipid that we were
looking for and we were generally having
a rather sort of morbid day and it's
quite worse because basically what
happened is you ain't - - damn
and Jean ray pointed out quite excitedly
look there's a little baby hippo that's
sleeping on the bank and so we thought
so that's very cute and we kind of
looked at it for a bit and then drove on
and and really pay too much attention
because we're trying to see if we could
find signal and we got to the little
baby hipper and then kind of some part
of me I don't know why just didn't
thinking something was right there and
so we drove along and then we stopped
and I said to John right now I need to
have one more look and so we went and
looked with bynars and we kind of saw
this little hippo was sitting there and
there was others that were nudging it
and this poor hippo was not moving in a
city Chandra something's taste pretty
wrong here so he went back and means to
go and have a look at what happened and
it was what's been transpired was
probably one of the most roughest and
hardest things that I've watched in a
long time essentially this poor little
baby hippo got violently attacked by
another hippo and it was picked up and
thrown around all over the place and the
mother tried to defend it they were
crocodiles that came in and it was
really quite something to kind of watch
this whole process take place and the
poor little baby
got kind of really badly injured and its
legs got broken and it was a really
horrible thing to see so I was quite
glad that we didn't have it live and if
we had signal issues at that time so I'd
put a really big dampener on our
afternoon yesterday eventually the
little baby did succumb to its injuries
and just disappeared under the surface
of the water and we didn't see it again
but I think the Crocs must have got it
at that stage but it was like I say one
of the more kind of depressing things
are that I have watched in nature
unfortunately it is part of nature and
there's not really much you can do about
it but watching that little baby being
picked up by that male and being shaken
and ran around with it was really quite
traumatic to be honest mrs. Elam you
said it sounds quite terrible and it was
really not very pleasant well no it was
horrible to watch it was not very nice
at all I mean but you know the one good
thing about the whole thing was that the
has kind of got attacked and you could
see it was suffering and then eventually
just went underwater and I think maybe a
croc aadat and just pulled it underneath
and that was the end of it so it didn't
suffer for hours and hours although when
we first got there it was already
injured so who knows how long it had
been going for but shame that poor
little baby was trying to fight with all
its life to kind of get itself back
towards the bank
to try and get safety on the land but it
unfortunately just couldn't get itself
out with its legs damaged it kind of got
to the edge of the water and was trying
to pull itself but it was couldn't to
his
it was like I say one of the most
heart-wrenching horrible kind of things
that we've watched so Nick you say you
glad that wasn't live yes I'm pretty
sure you and many others we're glad that
it wasn't alive or wasn't live it's at
that point we are gonna hit that wait in
case maybe the caucus is there now and
that you know now that it's dead it's
not so bad and you know various animals
will feed on it it might be interesting
to watch Vlad and Boris go about a kind
of feeding session but yeah it was was a
terrible thing to watch that's for sure
one like I said we need something to
improve our moods Chandra and I we owed
a beautiful sighting today because we
had the hard one yesterday and so we
need a good one today to just kind of
balance things out once again
well genre you got puppies this morning
and what did I get I got cold with the
wooden gate on date don't wrap it in
so many there's simple population
pressure so basically there was a
population issues that in chat oh damn
it's gone from 20 odd hippos to over 60
in fact I was told there was 63 hippos
counted in the dam the other day and so
that means that there's just far too
many hippos there what was interesting
about the whole thing was that it was a
very young male hipa that was doing this
and was bullying this poor mother and
there's a baby and then out of once all
this commotion had happened the big male
hippo actually came and he came swimming
across the dam and he went in there and
immediately all the nonsense stops
straightaway and he kind of disciplined
everybody and once he was there at all
calm down and the poor baby but the
damage was already done at that stage
and the baby kind of moved over to the
side and was already hurt but it's all
just to do with too many hippos into
smaller space and now they're starting
to fight with one another and maybe
trying to bring that female back into
Easter sits a young male that's dis
dosterone is flaring and so he's trying
his very best to kind of get that female
back into Easter's to be able to mate
with her that's pretty much what it is
much like lions killing their cubs and
just too many hippos in to smaller space
he's causing his but still very very sad
and I was really surprised at how that
young male was able to even pulley that
female into itsuka she knew he was about
the same size as her and I think she'd
just been fighting with him all day long
she looked like she had no more strength
left in her cuz at time she was kind of
trying to bite him and run next to him
but there was just really nothing she
could do use just intents on grabbing
that little one and in hurting it so not
very pleasant at all right now
unfortunately I once again using signals
so I can't really move from the spots
which is not very ideal at all and the
problem with that is that when one can't
move its makes life a little bit tricky
the other thing is is that we're having
terrible comms problems as well on rusty
which means I don't even know if we're
still alive oh you found a bird for me
well done John Dre now I can talk about
just over there they're on a termite
mound and there will be roughly the size
of a pixel I think on your screen but we
will make our way across there and see
exactly what it is that they're doing
I suspect they're just sleeping but
we'll see how many there are and then
decide whether or not we're going to go
with them down towards the wrists or
whether we'll just sit with him for a
little while
very exciting stuff I have no idea what
happened to that hippo Don adjuvant
sounds like an absolutely fascinating
sighting but I'm afraid I have no idea
so I cannot comment on it
apparently we're having technical
difficulties I don't know what those are
either but I apologize for them whatever
they are
and I do apologize for the banging noise
that is the
sorry I don't know what's going on what
are we talking about Emma
I don't even know if we live anymore oh
he was Tristan now
oh right the technical difficulties with
Tristan you're with me okay good
bit of confusion there managed to sorted
out now as far as I remember there isn't
a road that goes here so we're just
going to have to book off across the
fields which is no problem at all it's
quite fun
and just get past this little bottle
it's slash drain let's go this way
Kermie I've got no idea how the new
pride will react to the Cubs other than
to say probably like most lions reacted
to new lions they're normally quite
curious they are normally very
affectionate to start with the mother is
normally fairly defensive initially
because obviously she wants them to be
safe the mother will also be quite
careful about making sure that the
youngsters aren't bullied by the bigger
youngsters
I've seen two lionesses here so I don't
know if they're all here but that's
gonna have a look-see it is amazing how
easy they are to spot when they pick
their heads up because the white on
their fur really does reflect the light
now the big trick here is going to be to
decide whether or not we stay with these
guys and see if maybe one of them's the
mother and she'll go back down to feed
them or if we go down and sit with the
Cubs and wait for her to go to them I
don't know what to do we'll make that
assessment once we've seen how many
there are here and what they are doing
now there at least two lionesses there
and see one just over the other edge of
the termite mom I would go a little
faster if I wasn't afraid of mounting us
on a rock like I did yesterday during
our rehearsal we had to get out and well
extricate ourselves
oh and I think I can see others on the
termite mound beyond we might have the
whole pride here those are the lines or
they're just bits of lion colored dirt
um tell I think their lives nearly there
another two hundred or so meters five
hundred feet plus months
sorry Jenny you'll caught your question
broke up and right here slightly there
I got DG did Mara da da dee da da Das
Danny
Oh off-roading is permitted in some
parts of the Mara Jenny and not in
others because of the amount of activity
so in this area there's very little
activity and so we don't we you would
never have thousands of vehicles driving
off-road but up where the hola Lola
pride is obvious is right close to the
main entrance gate and you'd have far
too many people driving off-road to look
at the animals and so there'd be tracks
all over the place and ruts and nasty
gashes in the bush and that's basically
why so this particular area is
relatively vehicle free we quite toasted
sent an xenian border and that's why
we're allowed to go off-road here
naturally these guys put themselves into
a rock field hello ah and another one up
that one
Iko this is not technically a national
park technically this is a Conservancy
so it is paid for by donation business
private enterprise a little bit of
government funding that sort of thing
but it is attached to the National Park
that the Maasai Mara National Reserve
which is just across the Mara River
there is one lioness there are two
that's not the one I spotted there are
two lionesses on the termite mound to
the left of me at least we are going to
do a little arc and look around here to
see now I don't know how many of you are
good at identifying lions I'm utterly
horrendous at it so whether or not that
is meet either tree climber or not I
couldn't begin to tell you I'm afraid
certainly not this distance anyway and
then let's look at the others moon game
XI that one is not interested in us so
remember if you have just joined us the
sausage tree pride is five line is is
that's one of them
there two more over there and now there
are six Cubs
now the only reason I saw them from the
distance that I did is that one of them
popped her head up and you can see the
white fur on her throat that's what we
saw reflecting in the sunlight and
they're using these termite mounds
obviously for Vantage I think is the
first week in about four weeks that we
haven't seen them devouring the Buffalo
they are fast asleep because it is
really a Sunday afternoon that has that
sort of feeling about it
a sleepy Pleasant gentle Sunday
afternoon
I think the final controls talking to us
from Gary which I have got no comms I
just see the little arrow going oh I
think that was me sitting on my own
radio that's what it was
there we go alrighty let's go across to
Jamie she is searching for leopards I am
going to look around here and see
whether it's star radio
searching for anything actually to be
honest that's the unfortunate reality
that as a guide you know that on a windy
day you gonna struggle and not really in
terms of things like necessarily lion
sizing obviously this morning we had a
leopard sighting and a wild dog sighting
but just generally oh sorry Craig
there's some bad driving there just
generally you're going to struggle to to
find anything even in the general game
area just because they're all so nervous
everything hides away is there is a
reason why a lot of people gets nothing
spoken about this why a lot of people
get irritable or anxious or jumpy in the
rain and run in the rain in the wind
some people really struggle to tolerate
it I'm one of those people I get very
short short tempered in windy conditions
if it blows and blows and blows four
days at a time I find it effects my
psyche slightly I think that's also part
of being living out here and being very
closely connected to the weather or
exposed to the weather
animals really don't like it it's just
basically that simple so we've done a
whole loop around Gallagher SH pan and
up all the way down Gallagher shortcuts
and during that time a fly but me on the
ankle and I'm very cross
very eg Celtx wants to know if there be
any sightings of polka Maureen no yes no
not on Juma
haha
I've got it Steve don't you worry I'm in
there
[Music]
Thanks orbs I'm on my way
teehee oh yeah we got good news or
respond to ghana Jonin are the funny
news he's in exactly the same place as
he was
oh dear Lauren he must have just
disappeared down into some shade or
something oh dear okay well it also
serves me right I should have gone and
looked properly I didn't
okay well that's good I'm nearly there
I'm basically nearly there you okay
pressure loss pressures off a little bit
yeah okay
well there's greatly comforting and very
unusual fort in Ghana I must say I'm
very very surprised that he is in the
same place I really am
and this sort of whether it's in Ghana
likes to move but it's fine
he can hold off until 6:30 cheek cheek
says well spotted our Haji cheek I see
what you did there
it is definitely a very popular Safari
live joke about the wild spotted
leopards so well done Bravo
cheek cheek indeed I still haven't
spotted him yet we've got to just get
around Galago pan and then we'll be
there that is hilarious
it really is thank you
under the arch Linda says blame it on
the wind I do I do
okay so then what we need from you guys
I do blame it on the wind is if you
could please keep a very close eye on
the dam cam obviously don't stop
watching Safari live because I would be
a very poor poor presenter indeed if I
told you all to stop watching the show
so you could go watch the damn cam but
if you could watch the damn cam at the
same time and keep a very close eye out
for husana I mean I would a sneaky
suspicion he's very close round there
perhaps behind the dam wall somewhere
that side so if we can keep an eye out
for him that'd be awesome
okay now we just gotta hope Steve has
some luck
okay I'm nearly at our lipid I'm just
might take me some shuffling around to
get us a nice view so while we do that
let us bounce you back across said James
and the Mara who is still with his lions
let's see what they're up to now they
haven't moved we've come around and
looked about the place here the loss of
rocks we found we also found that there
are three Leone Isis that is all there
are no further and so where are the
other two I've got a horrible sinking
feeling that the mother has gone back to
the Cubs already and Reid managed to
miss her I could be entirely wrong they
could have gone hunting somewhere else
and be lying in the long grass but
that's the sort of conundrum I'm
constantly faced with do I go back to
the Cubs or do I stay here what we do
you've engaged said why don't you ask
the viewers I suppose I can't ask you
can't I try today he'll try the Cubs
again I will tell you the Cubs are
disappeared into the thick grass and I
also need to care bear in mind of course
that we have a television show to
deliver later today and well Cubs in
thick grass versus flat cats might be my
choice it's all free it's all very tough
everyone
yes I'm not surprised they pull that you
say Cubs Cubs Cubs one game predicted
that much as well he said he said why
don't you ask the viewers they'll tell
you to go back to the Cubs he was
exactly correct I don't blame you I
think I probably will you know we'll sit
here for a few minutes and then we'll
probably go back to the cubbies and just
wait it out I think that's our greatest
chance of spectacular success all of you
sang Williams go back to the Cubs now
okay that's your fault Gabriel that
depends entirely on how long you have
for me to answer you why it is that this
area has got no trees you see even this
lioness is quite interested fascinated
by the subject of why there are no trees
here the answer basically is humans and
elephants humans and elephants of the
reason that there are no trees in this
area so the story goes roughly as
follows by the time the turn of the 20th
century came so the end of the 19th
century this place was pretty full of
Masai people and their cattle it was
also full of wildlife but it was and
they kind of lived in a what would call
an uneasy harmony lots of people like to
think of rural Africans living in
harmony with nature no human being has
ever lived in complete harmony with
nature because by the very act of
existence and eating means that you
cannot live in complete harmony with
nature but that is an entirely different
discussion so basically let's go back to
1898 when we had the Maasai living in
the area they used a lot of wood they
used wood for furnaces to smelt for iron
they used wood to build their homes and
there were also a lot of elephants in
area at the time then what happened and
say you probably would find that this
area looked very similar to what it
looks like now then what happened was
the Italians who decided that because
all the other European powers had a
colony in Africa that they should have
one too
landed in Ethiopia probably a mistake
possibly the most organized African
state at the time they certainly had
took a number of fearful beatings from
the Ethiopians or Everson Yun's as they
were known then but they eventually
managed to get a foothold and they
brought a whole lot of cattle into the
area now the cattle carried a disease
known as the rinderpest and their
African crow animals both domestic and
wild had absolutely no immunity to this
disease and so every just about every
cloven hoofed animal down the Rift
Valley all the way from Abyssinia down
to South Africa and the Kruger Park died
of the rinderpest there were very very
few wild animals and cattle that
survived the rinderpest brought here
courtesy of the Italians who wanted a
colony back in 1898 I think it was 1898
anyway what that did was result in a
total exit of the people from this area
the Masai lost all their cattle so they
disappeared
out of the place the loss of the cattle
and the the thickening of the bush
brought back the tet see fly got very
thick in this area with jetty fly which
meant that the cattle and the people
didn't come back once the rinderpest had
gone and there were very low game
numbers at the time and then what
happened was probably around about the
1930s also the elephant started to come
and come back and they started to clear
out the bush a little bit and there was
also there was a band somewhere around
the mid 20th century on hunting in the
area and so the elephants were left
alone to deal with the kind of to deal
with the space and that's what they did
and the elephant started to clear away
the thickening bush that said see fly
disappeared from in air from areas like
this dust will occur in the woodland
of the Serengeti down in parts of the
Serengeti but in this particular area it
disappeared and that all allowed for the
re infinitely influx with the
repopulating for the growth in animal
numbers in wildlife animal numbers and
as the area was just sort of didn't
designated national park so the cattle
were never allowed back and it has been
maintained pretty much as it was since
about 1970 or so they reckon that the
ville de beast and zebra numbers reached
their current number so they haven't
changed a huge amount since the 70s so
the whole point of that story is that
this is yes it's a wilderness but it is
very heavily influenced by man and also
by that other supreme ecosystem
architect the elephant and also the
interesting thing about that story is
that people tend to think of this great
migration as being millennia old the
current one isn't it's only about 50
years old 40 or 50 years old which is
quite interesting in its current form
that animals migrated these Plains in
the dim mists of prehistory is almost
certain but the current migrations
current form is probably only 40 or 50
years old they're quite interesting I
think so there are the Lions they're
still there
all right Tristan's managed to find
himself some signal he's at a very
frustrating time of late I hope that it
manages to maintain for him no I'm sure
that was very interesting James
generally does have interesting things
to say and this giraffe probably was
listening intently about all of that
history too because he looks quite happy
and content with life as he chews on
whatever it is that he's regurgitated
and eaten and I say he because it is a
boy that is sitting there you can see a
rather large male that is behind us at
the moment it is a very very big giraffe
actually he's a very large individual
and very relaxed funny enough most of
the time giraffe can be quite sort of
shy with you they'll typically
particularly here in the sabi sands not
so much in the Mara but in Sands often
just kind of see you and then they move
away but this fella is really quite
happy with us being here looks
completely unperturbed by anything at
the moment as he chomps down like I says
regurgitated balls of leaves that he's
eaten during the course probably of the
morning and is just slowly ruminating
and having a bit of a rest
remember that giraffe when they do race
this is how they do it as they'll risk
standing up a lot of the time and they
sort of sleep pattern there's only
probably about 20 minutes a day and so
they don't really sleep that much but
this is a time when they ruminate and
they kind of resting pattern starts and
so that's all he's doing at the moment
and keeping a very watchful eye on us
now the reason we found this guy
actually is because we went past Quinn's
old hyena dinner not because we were
looking for eye eanes but we heard a
Franklin go absolutely crazy there and
so we thought maybe just maybe there
might be a leopard somewhere in the area
and so we came and had a little bit of a
look but alas we haven't found anything
and so we just on that little to track
at the moment and kind of bumped into
this fella over here and you can see how
he sticks up out of the bush and with
that long long Nick really is a very
kind of elegant looking creature that
you're off one notice one thing though
we're talking about they neck no I
thought I thought this would be the case
giraffe go and Billie age six are happy
to see giraffe yes I know that
you really enjoy giraffe so I'm glad
that you've managed to find one on Juma
of course there's a different species to
the one in the Mara this is a you know
southern giraffe as opposed to the
massager are that you see that side and
you really do get to see a lot of
giraffe and in Kenya as opposed to here
it's completely different you can't
actually go a drive without signature
off in Kenya whereas here we I know that
you can often do days and days and days
without seeing one of these fellows now
saying is Nick you can see there's
actually doing talking about his neck is
long but there's also a bit of damage to
it at the moment so it's got a little
wound on it and I'm just trying to see
if it's is a mange related wound or if
it is something to do with maybe you
know looks very much like potentially a
bit of mange that it's got on its neck
often you'll find it's giraffe they get
all kinds of different things
viruses on their necks they can suffer
from warts all over them they can get
these kind of be abrasive patches like
this so it could be that's it could be
an old wound that was opened up by
something that has just healed up it's
very very difficult to kind of say at
this stage but it looks very much like
maybe a little bit of mange that
developed there that he's rubbed raw I
know he's Nikki you're wondering about
what that is so it's quite common to see
injure off particularly big males we
often see all kinds of war wounds on
their necks and and all kinds of bits of
sort of parasitic growths and things
it's quite common to see anyway we're
going to carry on we're gonna try and
see if maybe we can find whatever was
causing this Franklin to be very upset
with its life and it certainly wasn't
this giraffe but Steve has got another
one of Africa's iconic big animals yes
indeed well they are generally regarded
as being quite grumpy
we found a for a small group of four
buffalo bulls that were just hanging out
in a little watering wallow we first had
us and a look at it nobs build duck
which was quite interesting and then we
heard oxpeckers and so followed the
oxpeckers and there we have got four
very grumpy looking boys who are in very
very good condition
they're of a jumpy though because the
wind is blowing and well we all know
what happens to these animals in the
wind a little bit skittish
obviously they always concerned about
lions trying to track them down isn't he
a magnificent specimen the enormous boss
on the top of his head hello Bobo do you
think he's grumpy well it's just what
they look like I think they're just very
badly understood poor buffalo bulls they
say all they want to do is just carry on
with their day and well most animals
well lions love to chase them this is a
hard time ready and when there are big
bulls like this they isolated from the
herd and far less sort of larger numbers
much easier to catch for the Lions
because they can isolate them but not an
easy thing to pull down a buffalo the
big boys like this maximum maximum
weight is up to about 2,000 pounds
probably closer to 1,600 in some cases
very big animal for a lion to try and
tackle but you can see they haven't lost
too much firm around the face the the
bosses are in perfect condition so I'm
going to guess these guys are sort of
towards the end of their tenure within a
herd they're not in the prime spots
anymore and that first guy we looked at
on the Left said his horns are worn down
quite a bit
yeah that's a great question I think
that's you in the same direction and
I've never really paid attention to that
that's all about the movement of the
lower jaw against them the mole is in
the top and the bottom and I think it's
always in the same direction let's have
a look shall we
that seems to be the same direction
they're hiding behind this small bush
thinking we can't see them busy
ruminating building up their condition
it's been a very long year
in the last rains that we had we're in
about April and we did get some green
vegetation from that but in all in all
these Buffalo are quite happy with the
rain that has fallen now we have got
some good green vegetation for them to
bulk upon and that is exactly what they
are doing
[Music]
okay well we might move off from this
Buffalo we might do a little loop around
see if we can find the lions trying to
track them but it means aren't let's go
back over to Jamie with the Juke of Juma
I have had some luck and I owe that luck
entirely to Aubrey who showed it but
more common sense then I did this
afternoon and went and checked where
ting gana was and didn't buy into the
tracks that we saw earlier so there we
go
anyone would be forgiven for not knowing
he was there I mean really he's
underneath Jesus leopards love weeping
waffles he's underneath her weeping
wattle in a thick patch of grass I mean
if you didn't know he was there you
could so so easily miss him so that's
where he is I'm parked here because it's
the one patch of shade but since the
sun's very kindly gone behind a cloud I
can't actually take you for a better
future semi maybe a second as clutch
keeps I thought it was me I thought I
forgot how to drive a few days ago and
that I was just letting in the clutch
are too fast but it's not it's actually
the clutch isn't doing so well
when we were talking about animals
pickup lines I thought I'd forgotten how
to drive and I really hadn't we'll get
it fixed eventually but if you see me
suddenly jerk forward and Craig lands in
the seat next to me
well isn't a seat next to me anymore he
lands there then we know under yes ever
was not I was distracted by thinking of
pickup lines
I felt like we weren't doing our best we
weren't living up to our potential there
which is the world's worst pick-up line
there we go so good to get let me just
see if someone was looking for me I
think that was actually for Steve give
me one moment
he has been easy look at how flat in the
grasses
he has been having the best time
hey my boy you found yourself a little
Kevin of shade and shelter away from the
wind
Dingaan oh that looks incredibly
comfortable
it really does it looks you know when
you read children's books when you're a
kid in you you read books about people
flopping down in the soft long grass and
it always sounds so romantic and then
all of a sudden you actually try it
yourself and you find that there's a
blade of grass up your nose in your ear
you itchy because you having a skin
reaction to it or maybe it's just me
grass is never as comfortable as you
think it is or maybe some in different
parts of the world you've got some
really nice grass I remember as a kid
with nice lawn grass I suppose but
really it was never quite as comfortable
and experience as you expected it to be
tingly doesn't seem to have that problem
though he really is quite content where
he is yes mister big sleepy kitty cat
when are you going to call I have not
heard you call in weeks I know that he
was calling the other morning Sydney had
him I think it was with Craig actually
are we looking for them give you one
second guys standing by Dave
no problem Dave you actually need to
take the first right but it's quite far
down so there is a two-track about
halfway down the road that you must
ignore but it's very clearly a two-track
not a road and then you take the first
road to the right and you'll go through
a dip and you should actually see me as
you come up through the other side but
I'll let you know when I hear you
obviously just giving some directions it
occurred to me as I was saying take the
first road to the right so that if he
did that he might actually end up at the
ANU Road hyena den which would not be
ideal my one needs a fearsome sense of
direction out here particularly in the
Mara but here on jhummer as well let us
hope that James is able to find his way
back towards the lion cubs I think I've
got a good direction at the moment
simply because the son is obviously to
my left so I know where I'm going
slightly disconcerting because at this
time of the year the Sun sets very far
southwest as opposed to west so that is
not west whist is much more over there
but disconcerting well so we've left the
lionesses we've left the lionesses on
their termite mound because you told us
to and so we're now coming down towards
the big fig tree I'm taking a slightly
different route back to them from the
one that I took to them simply to see if
the other two aren't between here and
the fig tree
but adds yet there's really not much
going on this particularly really big
herd of elephants off to the left it's
just keep going and quite far away and
into the Sun oh sorry
let's go cluster Stephens got dogs
welcome back
but could refound folks we have found
the Hamilton pack of wild dogs or just
on the southern side of Gary Maine right
now not far from where we were moments
ago with those Buffalo and they are
behaving like dogs do if you look
closely then lots of the well obviously
the younger ones are begging that's very
hard to tell the difference that they're
all very much the same size but I've
never seen this many dogs before in my
life is this so incredible see all their
ears a flat trying to some of them are
begging trying to get some food it would
seem from the adults it's possible that
they've maybe hunted I can't see any
carcass in any of anywhere near by a
super super special to Dell to spend
time with wild dogs but unfortunately
they're just on the southern side but
there seem to be taking a little bit of
a rest now who knows how long how far
they've moved there we go the life of a
dog cool breeze would be very special if
they did but hopefully if they made a
kill there do it on our side of the road
and that should be much much better
wouldn't it you probably hear some
people laughing there's a couple of
vehicles in the sighting obviously they
all here to see the wild dogs as well
and I can't get over the smell they've
got such a particular smell I can't
really place it it's like a sweetness
but like a dirty sweet and I've smelt it
before when I followed them and now when
we were sitting here there was just this
lingering sort of sweaty sweet smell
coming off of them and it's a very
characteristic smell when you've smelt
it once always recognize it do you know
what I mean said
the Sabres spent a lot of time with dogs
he knows exactly what I mean they are
enjoying a little bit of shade hopefully
they come north wouldn't it be marvelous
if we got to see them on the TV show
this evening get them running through
Juma and hunting be very very special
indeed they are regarded as great
particular animals they're diurnal
animals safari love it it's there's a
sourness to it but it's a sweetie so
it's very hard to me to really put my
finger on that smell um I wish I could
bottle it for you and send it wherever
you are so you could smell what I smell
it's like a dirty sweet art critic
that's as good as I can explain it but
they've probably been active during the
day they're probably well a clan of this
a pack of the SAS needs to hunt
regularly 18 wild dogs it requires a lot
of food but formidable they are any
animal that they come across is a fair
game such one got a col s it yeah yeah
there's that one of the leaders probably
there's lots of research being done in
South Africa with regards to cheetah and
wild dog the movements the distributions
and it really is quite incredible how
far these animals are capable of moving
constantly in the search of food only
really resting only really resting when
they have puppies in a den site
somewhere other than that they're just
moving for the landscape Jamie says we
should do a scratch and sniff book for
safari that should be a great idea Jamie
we'd be able to get all of the wonderful
smells and leopard urine I don't know at
us right now
elephant in masks that should be a good
one as well water buck definitely water
buck wild dog we might leave some of the
really bad smells out of there though
because they are
some horrible smells that you really
done wants to be sharing with anybody
like lion poop says sip indeed lion
scat or leopard sket not the most ideal
smells in the world if you've ever
driven in some of it you will never ever
forget that smell but we could get at
least you know a number of pages even
the texture book as well a smell and a
texture you could feel cuz I know
Tristan was talking about the feel of
wild dogs yesterday and what exactly
their feel like so that would be nice to
be able to touch we'd have to leave the
poop section are completely indeed Emma
I don't think of any poo is really worth
being smelt I don't think so actually
the elephant dung has got a nice and
sweet smell to it sometimes the
contrasting smell of elephant poo versus
the elephant's skin itself it's a very
very nice organic sort of smell okay
well we're gonna stay with these dogs
hopefully they get up and move on to our
side and in the meantime let's go and
get Jamie's thoughts on Assam elephant I
am smelling absolutely nothing's
unfortunately the wind is blowing the
scent of the elephants away from me but
if it were blowing the center towards me
I would I would be smelling the smell of
dry skin and grass the scent that I
associate with elephants I've been over
the scratch and sniff book thing with
many of you before we've discussed it on
the Lives safaris quite often and the
thing is you've gotta have the full
experience you've got to have wild
aniseed wild basil jasmine elephants
yeah big fan nearly but you've also
gotta have to do because in 40 degree
temperatures and then you know when
we're sitting next to it we'll say to
you guys Kate turn to page
294 made that reference before as well
those of you feeling really sharp this
afternoon and you will smell dead
Buffalo today old dead Buffalo or
something nice you all smell the smell
of Africa after the rain that I feel is
the most elegant solution to how we can
involve your olfactory senses in this
experience you know we can we can let
you listen to the sounds usually when
it's not howling with windy we can let
you watch what's going on but we cannot
include smell it would be quite a book
there's quite a collection you know it's
all sorts of things one would have to
include in there Prince Pete
what else would we include Emma nemesis
that doesn't seem relevant listen as
part of the safari experience you've got
to you ought to be all encompassing all
the girls no I will stick with the
animal smells I can say the perfume and
stuff but I think we can scrap that
sunblock you have to at any point you
have to be able to smell the smell of
sunblock as well that's a crucial part
of this whole deal I've left in Ghana
obviously I have not left him for good
I'm going straight back there I just saw
these guys dashing across with a true
elephant water walk which is basically
they thirsty thirsty thirsty and in a
big hurry and I know that I knew the
water was just here so I just ditched
him for a little bit he better not go
anywhere I'll be very embarrassed if he
does oh what's he doing he trying to
steal water out of your friends mouth
that's not going to work very well I'm
so thrilled for Steve that he got to see
the Hamiltons pack I had such a
wonderful sighting this morning and I
know that he was quite jealous we were
talking about it this morning and how
excited he gets seeing wild dogs as we
all do so I'm really really glad that he
got to got to see them especially
because he was helping me out search for
10 Ghana so I'm very happy with that
all right I'm gonna head on back to
Tenggara before he decides it to happen
off in a different direction we'll send
you back across to James and perhaps he
can tell you what he's smelling in the
Maasai Mara so here you are your wish
our command we are sitting with the
little Cubs with exactly the same place
as we were but all three of them just
snuggling together it's just water it's
a lion cubs back didn't love to snuggle
and play and suckle
planta Jamie's wondering if I've had
snuggles with the Cubs
I couldn't believe Jamie really asked if
I had snuggles with these Cubs now the
answer's no I haven't that would be a
silly thing to do oh it's
apparently she was talking about
elephant smells and she wants to know if
I can smell anything
not the reciting here no I cannot smell
anything other than the grass around me
which is delightful I suspect you'll
find that lion cubs don't smell her very
much at all I know I do bang on about
this but I think the fastidious
cleanliness that the adults subject them
to the surface to disbar thing that the
adult subject them to means that they
don't smell like much except Zion and I
think you'll find that that's enough to
deter most creatures from an area like
this they'll come in here smell lion
just avoid it they won't smell lion cub
[Music]
I mean that said I don't know what lion
smells like I know what wild dog smells
like but lion I don't think there's no
very strong at all Allen the only thing
these things eat at the moment is
Mother's Milk
I'm afraid it's also one of the reasons
that lion cubs are a lot more active
than adult lions her diet is full of
fatty milk which gives them a lot more
energy than the meat of their parents
it's just really very special
my last wish for the Sunday is that they
continue to perform like this as we go
into our TV show because if they just
disappear into the bush and lie down our
show we deeply disappointed with them
I suppose you might also be able to hear
a couple of frogs calling nothing
there's a bubbling casino going in the
stream below us
I must say it's one of the great
disadvantages of driving cars around the
bush as opposed to walking and that is
the ability to smell in here obviously
we sitting now and so we can hear
everything but the odor of a vehicle
like this is fairly overpowering so
unless you in some pretty aromatic
vegetation and you can basically smell
Land Rover 90% of the time and when
they're Land Rovers the sold that's not
entirely a good thing and this a breeze
blows across the car on which guests in
the glorious smells of the bush tumble
to the fall
okay I'm gonna disturb you and ask you
to put the camera in the top of that
gardenia bush they're mine
some little finch like birds naturally
there and the next bush in the quarry
bush flying around and gone what a pity
naturally as soon as we decide all there
we go Oh little wax bill I think it's a
common wax bill or something similar me
see yes
Puma as we go back to the Cubs I will
try and identify that works well for you
now I'm 99% sure that if a human was to
touch the Cubs the parents would or the
mother would definitely be able to smell
it and I think she'd be deeply put out
but but I don't think she would reject
the cub at all so that was just a common
wax bull that's what I thought it was
pretty sure it was
so pretty sure because they can look
fairly similar but I'm pretty sure we
had a common wax pool their only thing
it might been confused with his a
crimson of lumped black spill which we
don't get inside I forgot the common wax
bull we do we also get Lions in South
Africa of course not at the moment but
we do get them there this is the most
adorable stage of lion life
I'm sure if you have a small child they
thought of handing one of those things
to them as they go to sleep must be
extremely appealing because they look so
cuddly they look like they're just
snuggle up to whatever came near them
and they will grow so fast and they lose
this teddy bear look in about three
weeks and I know many of you not moving
and eyeing and say this is a totally or
total cuteness overload it is absolutely
now you can sex them at this age if they
were to turn on and lift their little
tails would be able to do it so we could
be able to tell whether there are male
or female and guys just got a small part
of tuberculosis he's trying to give it
up I actually think he's just eaten some
nuts and that's what he's confident
[Music]
okay if we were sitting at a concert of
Mozart's 23rd piano concerto it would be
used but coughed out let's do the quiet
section you know now everybody that it
is definitely live because we would
never edited boom guys cough into it
learned still fascinated by our presence
which is fantastic I am to quote Brent
Leo Smith keeping my head on a swivel to
see if I can spot any of the others
around him giraffe girl mr. ham fried my
brain exploded when I looked again at
these cute lines well cats Pat's this is
sorry cannot catch passes just pass
isn't it Pat I don't know entirely how
they know but they do know obviously as
they get older
sorry I just realized I've moved my hat
which is gonna sound terrible lifted
learn up so does cats not pet cat I
don't know how they know to stay they do
know to stay though and as they get
older they will move around a little bit
more and their mothers you'll find we'll
have to go and look for them slightly so
they'll just slowly start to explore
more and more as they get a bit older
but we watched last week with the older
Cubs when the mothers smelt something
that they thought they wanted to
investigate and they did something and
it was totally impossible to see what it
was that they did but the three cubs
turned around walked in the opposite
direction and went flat in the grass and
the three lionesses carried on they went
to investigate around a termite mound
quite possibly they thought there was a
warthog there there wasn't a warthog
there they got onto the termite mound I
think one of them made one little
contact call and the Cubs came back to
them so how they told the little ones to
go away while they hunted I don't know
it certainly wasn't something that I was
able to pick up
they've got these dark deep eyes at this
age or the slightly navy blue tinge
ester Arco you'd say their little
sausages will they aren't they a little
chipolatas at this edge
oh my goodness we just have to hope that
this day here
you can't see the little claws of the
one there on the belly sticking out they
remind me of my nephews alrighty we're
gonna go back to Steve and his dogs I am
NOT going anywhere at all
well thanks James unfortunately our dogs
have just gone a little bit too far from
the road and all we can see is bushes so
unfortunately we did have them for their
foot to go up but they've just moved off
a little bit too far into the bush now
and they're all lying down so we can't
even see them anymore trying to get
another view happy managed to get to in
the open surprisingly camouflaged the
wilds dog she's quite a better dolt
yeah good that's her thankfully telling
a little bit of age so I was mentioned
before the Thera garden is diurnal
hunters but when it's very hot they'll
really be active in crepuscular time so
dusk and dawn but very efficient hunters
probably the most successful out of all
the predators when they hunt they are
always well generally successful they
pull down medium to large sized prey
such as Impala couldn't I never seen
them go for a vole the best that would
be quite interesting to see what they
would do with her for the best
I think the wildebeest would turn and
use its horns to defend itself but 18
individuals would be quite something to
try and fend off the red crested core
hon somewhere in the middle of them in
the middle of the wild dogs being a very
brave bird so we spend a lot of time
last year with the investigator way and
these are apparently the Hamilton clan
pack also so nice to see you dogs on the
property but I suppose there's nothing
cuter than a leopard cub but a second
place would most certainly be the new
Cubs of the sausage tree pride
now especially when they're playing
nothing cuter than Cubs look at those
little claws that have come out there
they will be sharp as needles they don't
come out when scratching brother or
sisters face oh my goodness this is just
too wonderful
snuggling and playing all at once Andy I
don't think mum would be concerned with
us around the Cubs if she arrived here I
think she is familiar enough with
vehicles to not see us as a threat at
all and I think if we were standing
around on foot trying to hand-held shoot
this scene you know walking about the
place I think then should take exception
very quickly but no I don't think she'd
be upset if she found us here I just
can't wait to see if she arrives
I keep scanning the clearings either
side of me so far no sign of any adult
lioness here so we did have the three
back on the termite mounds there
like I say my ability to identify
lionesses by looking at them in this
they've got half an ear missing is
really very poor and so I don't know if
the mother was one of the three that we
saw
but I don't think so
[Music]
right 10 Ghana I believe has got up he
started to move which is excellent I
like Tristan and Jamie hope that he
makes us all we are in deeper Dingaan is
taking us into this block I was gonna
actually show it to you on a map and
then I forgot he's taking I'm glad we
came we left those alleys when we did
because he got up and moved straight
away as we got back to him so he's
taking us into the drainages where I
have to warn Emma signal gets a little
bit shaky on no he's going across ah
there ain't no way across here guys
through the best of my knowledge this is
where we lost him with Tristan a while
to go out try to get there so just to
warn you he seems something and I my boy
he has steam he's listening to something
I cannot get through the step I can only
hope that he turns and goes back towards
whatever he's listening to off to the
left there I said East 10 Ghana East but
no we're gonna have to have a chat about
this he's very hungry he's all skin flap
and nothing else I mean he looks good he
looks healthy nice and muscular but he's
really really hungry oh man this is
going to be incredibly difficult oh good
kitty cat
it's really not going to help us though
is it because you're just going to lie
there for two seconds and then you're
going to go down aren't you I'm scared
to start the car to even get us a better
view because often what happens is with
the movement of vehicles it's not that
the animals disturbed or frightened in
any way it's just you know obviously
they listen to the noise so then they
listen and they think aha I'm awake now
anyway I might as well move so often
what happens is if someone drives past
an animal or something or moves out of a
sighting the animal gets up and moves
not away from the vehicle just because
the noise has created movement I think
it's something in this drainage look at
him gone if you're gonna kill something
it's got to be the side eh I don't have
signal on the other side mrs. Anna says
that mating burns calories he did he
didn't really do much proper mating
though did he I mean he was worth 20 for
that brief brief moment where they
encountered each other then it looks
like from the tracks Tristan was saying
that they mated again that night
presumably a few times but after that he
was separated from her and he moved off
I don't know why don't tristan suspects
that there was some sort of meeting of
females in that southern section it's
basically the southern boundary of
Tandy's territory and that during all of
the drama king gana took the opportunity
to escape and moved up here so he's he's
had two days of mating as far as we know
we could of course be mistaken but we've
had no evidence of him mating and
typically mating lepers don't move very
far more find out I mean if we spend a
bit of time with him let's look at ways
looking grief if he kills something in
there we are in big trouble it will be
the end of our lipid for this TV show
which isn't a disaster it's not all
about the lipids it's just nice to be
able to
introduce South Africa to some of our
beloved characters
Eric in Montreal he wants to know if
that is a tick on his left ear yes it is
at the base there you can just see it it
is assert a t getting old boy yes that
is a tick at the join between his ear
and his cheek a big very engorged tick
as it happens he's listening intently
tristan actually told me that he saw
that in ghana had two ticks the other
day and very inappropriate in a very
inappropriate place i can't see them
anymore so fortunately it seems as
though he's managed to remove them and
he said he had one on each testicle it
must have been very uncomfortable he
looks fine there alright alright
everybody cross your fingers hold your
thumbs cross your toes if you have to
wish us luck and that he doesn't go
north meantime if we go back across to
Steve who I'm sure is thinking much the
same thing thanks Jay meeting Ghana
hopefully he will stick around for this
evening
we just had a lovely visual of a grey
horn ball that caught a caterpillar and
was wiping it against the branch for a
very long time and then well he finally
swallowed it and disappeared just trying
to see if I could see him again that
he's vanish was really nice
really to enjoy their caterpillars this
time of year most of the horn bolts are
the females are hidden away in cavities
in the trees where the male is not
providing all of the food in the form of
insects for them good afternoon
I hope good afternoon likewise cheers
guys
it just getting fast some apparently
some super fans staying it
I think it's gala go they were
interested in those Buffalo we've
obviously left the wild dog we couldn't
see them anymore which is a little bit
too far off the road and we'll go back
there rather than the show see if maybe
if they get up come back on it'll be
nice and in the meantime we're gonna
keep checking our watering holes and we
art a tree house see if there's any
tracks of horse onna materializing
anywhere nothing as of yet I wonder if
there's wild dogs no there is such a
lovely little watering hole here that
they can come and spend some time at but
anyway while we keep searching hopefully
we'll find other little chief let's go
back up to the muss mr with James and
his adorable little Cubs
well all the cuteness has now gone to
sleep this is the as I said earlier the
fashion for young mammals they use all
their energy and then they go to sleep
and that's what these chaps are doing
now fast asleep waiting for their mother
to come back we are of course thanks to
you lot everybody in a high-risk
assiting situation here simply because
if they move even slightly away from us
now they will become invisible so if
their mother comes back she's going to
have to oblige us by lying just in front
of them to feed them I'm very very kind
of her she did that there was a little
foot and you just want to go over there
and hold it and like you do that the
hast kept push it's little claws out and
see them come out and go back in again
cool
but I'm afraid not an INT or enormous
amount of activity you can hear a red
eye dived going in the top of the trees
Lily absolutely having a pride helps
with calves survival without a pride the
Cubs would most certainly die and the
bigger the pride is well the more likely
they are to be able to look after these
Cubs and make sure that they survive now
we know that this pride of course is
five lionesses
and they are protected or dominated by
the two old on your pike males I haven't
seen any other lions in this area and so
I think you know as far as other lions
go they're pretty safe but I've seen
baboons coming through here hyenas
elephants buffalo all sorts of creatures
that could pose a threat to the lion
cubs remember interestingly lion cubs
don't tend to climb like leopard cubs do
I mean they can they just tend not to
and so they don't often take that option
for safety gorgeous sunset going on
there through the back of the trees I
was just trying to sneak a look around
the side of the vehicle to see if
anything was coming through the
clearings not that I can see just yet
will engine like most things pros and
cons you say good things they've got the
eye grass to hide in amongst yes it is
but it doesn't mean that they can't push
the mute button sorry about that I
pushed the mute button I'm M Jin what
you'll find is that yes certainly it's
easier to hide in thick grass but it's
also very difficult for to see over
thick grass so if you think of the life
of a warthog in this area I don't think
they're like this time of year at all I
think there must truly dislike it a lot
because well they can't see anything yes
they can hide but if you can't see what
you're hiding from it's often a
disadvantage so yes maybe for lion cubs
it's a good thing but they cannot see
anything that is coming to get them
they are perfectly positioned for us at
the moment it really is wonderful
and they're very tired now
and one of my very favorite sounds in
Africa is the sound of the red-eyed dove
and I don't think that you'll find it
that's Jula
oh that's awesome I'm glad there - James
is enjoying the sounds of the Mara and
still with sin God is still in the same
place so you know positive positive
vibes perhaps all of your thoughts being
with us helping us out here he's
listening to something that's making its
way towards us now my hope here and it
is it is really a true shot in the dark
is yes that way yes right look no no no
that's wrong
self ting god it looks off gotta go pans
right there everything's gonna go for a
drink that's the way you want to go my
only hope is that something walks into
him here really plenty of nice trees to
hoist into it's along a river system
it's a very steep river system actually
I can show you now oh maybe I can't
because now I don't think I have any
signal if you can bear with the slight
blue tinge to my and there we go
actually that sort of works don't move
so if I try how's the glare there cream
Hui there is a are we good cool there we
go brilliant perfect okay so those dark
green lines over there these ones here
down here these are all river systems
that are incredibly steep and as you can
see there's multiple river systems so
there's a split which is where we were
with him and then there's this little
one here oh yes up here from galago
shortcut shortcut and down because you
can't get across this way so you can't
once you lose him through here that's
tickets really and unless you get very
very lucky I happen to know the secret
to track that runs from galago shortcut
shortcuts to the strange line and the
reason we know it so well is because
remember when Corolla had the which was
it was a bush but kill and Hassan and
gyeonggido we're with her and then the
wild dogs came running through and they
killed an yalla and then
Carola went and trotted up and grabbed
the the remains of it and looked very
proud of herself and put it in the tree
next to her bushbuck there that's the
secret way in but to get there I have to
go all the way around there's a reason
that we can't even if we were able to
drive down the steep banks of the
strange the problem is is that it's one
large tambuti thicket which we cannot
drive over Debbie he has been sawing
Debbie wants know what the reasons are
why he is he's not suing or st. marking
he was sawing a couple of days ago with
Sidney Sidney heard him from chit to
Adam but what's confusing me is that
whenever he comes into this part of his
sort of western edge of Juma which is of
course his boundary with with nakamori I
haven't heard him and he's not so he's
definitely not solving as often now I
don't know why that is I don't know if
tonight perhaps might be the exception
and he's going to saw beautifully fuss
it could be that he's not feeling up to
a fight it could be that he is he is
then he is hungry
I mean he's so looking muscular a big
boy but perhaps he isn't feeling up to
up to a battle I just I'm not sure maybe
he's getting old it was around about
this point that a mullah started to
retire to the north he still made the
odd appearance on Juma but that was I
mean that was about four years ago now
went in Ghana took over from the West I
don't know how much sewing he's doing in
Buffalo
but he's been largely silent here and
that's what's worrying me
well the only thing I can say is that I
hope I hope that he sticks around long
enough for husana to grow into his new
role right speaking of cubs growing up
and James as lion cubs apparently look
as though they're going to be up to
mischief shortly it's an interesting one
that the Jaime is talking about being
worried that Tenggara isn't sawing it
said I suppose I feel kind of the same
but the problem is the more you worry
about it I said what am I trying to say
here it's inevitable he's going to stop
sawing eventually he's going to not be a
territorial male leopard anymore
eventually he's going to get old and
he's going to dive into a we know that
this is inevitable it's going to happen
to all of us and the more every time we
worry about it the closer we are to it
actually happening because every day
that passes we are closer to the day
that Tenggara will go into retirement
that's also inevitable there is no way
around that
and it's interesting worrying about
whether or not he's finally soared his
last it's interesting to worry about
something that is completely inevitable
and I am exactly the same i every time i
hear tristan look at Tenggara and say
who i haven't heard him call for a while
i get a little heart palpitation it
would make it'll make me extremely sad
the day that ting garner does retire but
it is entirely inevitable and isn't it
funny how despite the fact that it is so
completely inevitable we still worry
about it I can't explain it
three little things are nowhere close to
retirement we hope but of course what
isn't so inevitable is the death of
youngsters and certainly it feels a lot
worse than the death of aged animals and
people and we've lost one of these
already as I said they were four to
start with when they were found and
there are now three and that also seems
like air
I suppose it's almost more of a loss
because well it's almost against the
order of nature except that it isn't if
you're aligned nine out of ten Cubs will
not make it to adulthood or to
independence
quite an astonishing ratio of success to
failure um yes absolutely Colleen and
eagle would certainly try for a cub
probably an owl more likely in this
habitat but absolutely an eagle or try
for these Cubs and successfully take one
I mentioned the other day that I had
seen a video of an owl spotted eagle owl
taking a white tailed Mongoose it wasn't
a white tailed Mongoose I watched it
again it was a a striped polecat which
is basically the African version of a
skunk and it's substantially smaller
than a white tailed Mongoose and
probably about the same mess as these
little lines these lines will smell a
lot bitter though
already the little instinct to clean I'm
90% sure that has got to do with trying
to remain unstable to prey and predator
keep staring to the clearings behind us
no arrival of any lioness stage
son slowly starting to sit now
yes mo it does look a little bit like
the Cubs enjoying my stories I don't
think it is in actuality I think it's
probably just enjoying the afternoon the
lovely soft green grass that's lying in
the absence of obvious danger of course
two Cubs like this they're oblivious to
danger until it actually hits them might
find the sound of my voice intriguing
because it's slightly unusual compared
with what they've experienced for the
rest of the day which was nothing just
the natural bush sounds around them
you're a frog Cody Franklin bridai dad
no Safari had they're not the same Cubs
as David has been looking at david has
been looking at the other three the four
month old and the two five month olds
who were around here this morning and I
suspect are still around here somewhere
would be nice to have them on camera as
well so no they are not the same David
certainly was suspicious that these
things were about to be born
or just born as he left so he's going to
be delighted and jealous and equal
measure when he returns to find that
these little sausages have been born to
his pride of lies he spent a lot of time
here in the last six to eight weeks and
it's been a real honor coming to replace
him for a little while I must say
tremendous to come down and spend time
in this utterly magnificent area
no child of the universe are not going
to tell the Lions a story of being
fierce and scaring human beings I don't
want them to be scary just yet
they're innocent we want them to remain
innocent and unaware of the violence and
trauma that is going to characterize
their lives as adult Lions in the same
way that I try and not tell my nephew's
lovely violence and trauma that humanity
has wrought upon their world well so I'm
going to try and feel these things from
that sort of thing for now
I'll tell them later there but maybe in
a few months
only animal in the keyring close to us
is a totally way behind
the slowly began to have to put on the
infrared I think fairly soon not just
yet but fairly soon
we have a question from Lucia moi
the black cat you want to know how much
I get paid to babysit I get paid in oh
look let's just have a quick look there
it's a little lioness that's almost
certainly a little lioness shraddh Noir
I don't get paid to babysit I get paid
in the thrill of being around these
little Cubs I am 99% sure that what
you're looking at there is a lioness
well we'll be a lioness so we've got one
she she's a bit Taylor than the other
two I think maybe that's how we can
identify her oh they're just utterly
adorable unpack
she is a poser Ellie absolutely right
and thankfully all three of them are
quite keen on being on camera
they weren't they could quite easily be
in the thicket and totally invisible
look
what was an outstanding pleasure and
privilege to build a sitting area like
this yes I'm at work on a Sunday but you
know what better place would you rather
be I mean I think if most of you would
choose where to holiday on a Sunday this
is probably exactly where you choose to
be as I've been sitting here for the
last two and a half three hours or so
enjoying a magnificent sunset enjoying
the smells and sounds of a Masai Mara
and three of its cutest residents I also
think jhummer if a lioness is
approaching for example you'd probably
hear it coming because of the woodland
and the number of trees and the trees
and the number of birds in the trees is
what I mean and they would then indicate
the arrival of a lioness firearm calling
we didn't have quite the same number of
trees here so the birds closer to the
ground they don't tend to make so much
noise
you know they look at up at it was
slight very distant roll of thunder
Rati I believe that the old Duke worried
as we are about him is still quite
hungry
I know ins make tea definitely the Duke
of jummah is very hungry I've lost him
and I've come in the direction that he
was walking in just I there's not much
else I can do and we've bumped into the
steak that's directly on the path that
he was taking now I don't know if he's
gone further deep down into the drainage
line if he even knows that the steak is
here or if there was something else that
he was looking at and looking for a
little Degas Upjohn it seems it's
amazing how animals have a sixth sense
about whether or not there's a predator
around there's just something that tells
them he's looking Dacus looking back he
was coming from come on Dingaan oh come
on I'm trying to look down into the
drainage line itself than Kay he died
without me realizing it the fact that
he's not sawing is making life very very
difficult he's going to make life very
difficult that I want to move now just
in case he is stalking oh it's one of
those debates you saw yesterday how long
husana took in heart invisible he was
singhania's in there I don't I'm not
gonna know about it
I don't know if he's hunting I don't
know if he's walking I've really just
left with guesswork yeah and that's
basically all we have although ting
Ghana's capable of taking down an
antelope much larger than the stake he's
not going to shy away from it so he's
hungry any meal is a meal so if he has
seen mistake er this is exactly what he
is going to go for if this is what he's
seen I don't see anything else I don't
see anything y'all I don't see any
Impala so I'm hoping that this is what
he's after a little de coeur hidden down
in the depths of this incredibly thick
block I'm sorry you'll notice I'm not
paying a hundred percent attention to
you or to the data cuts just in case he
walks right past and we miss him
Oh Dingaan a you horrible kitty cat he's
got to do what he's got to do
do we know you wouldn't be sawing if
he's so close to pray he definitely
won't give it away seen to God I do some
odd things we've seen him go into what
looks like full hunt mode and then all
of a sudden go into a territorial saw
when the hunt failed her no real clear
reason that he wouldn't really be
swinging if he was actively hunting this
is just this is a gamble I'm gambling
completely I don't have any many very
options I'm so far into this block now
and by the team of crime the TV show
ends I would have found my way out of it
it's a slight exaggeration but oh yeah
Eric says a classic at in Ghana yep
pretty much he loves this block it's all
the LIF it's cruelly used to love this
block - and ting gone and does as well
so it's one of those things where they
it's you know you know I'll schedule I
don't know we have a TV show tonight it
really doesn't matter to them so it
really is just them doing their natural
thing and us having to roll with the
punches I'm not actually that stress you
know there's plenty of animals in
quarantine hassanis tall m.i.a somewhere
I was sort of in my my wild dreams
hoping that Tenggara might find her sana
for us hello little Decker would you
please walk this way so that if ting
gone
okay as this Dacre disappears off as
well
we better send you across to Steve I
hope he's having some luck on his side
thanks Jamie
I hoped in Ghana well for the data's
sake hopefully doesn't catch him but
foots in Ghana sake I hope he does that
should be really really nice 4:14 garner
seem to have headed further south from
where there were not coming back on to
Juma so we have been investigating why
don't you find any tracks and it is very
very hard going
meanwhile dog tracks all over the place
but may be difficult to see a leopard
track in amongst all of that so we've
been searching at length for the little
chief we're now going to fun if it's up
it proved a sucker
watching hope see if we can get anything
eh it's been an afternoon of checking
the water once again all the little pans
and puddles along the way to see what we
can see
the bumpy on the corner here hold on sip
so I'm looking forward to seeing some
screenshots of James with his lions how
amazing it is to be able to spend time
with brand-new Cubs it's a very very
special privilege that we have and James
seems to have having a very nice time
this afternoon well on that note talking
about James I need to go all the way
back up to the Maasai Mara to say
farewell to him in the sausage tree
pride caps right well we haven't moved
the little cubbies have moved a little
bit I can hear some alarm calling birds
around here and I'm wondering if maybe
we don't have the arrival of either the
other three Cubs or knelt but I don't
think that's going to happen before the
end of our show I'm afraid so you just
can't have to make do with these
delightful little things on their own
I'm quite sure you don't mind in the
slightest
yes Shannon mothers will abandon their
cubs from time to time it does happen
it's normally if there's starvation or a
severe threat from marauding males
remember that if a mother decides to
defend her cubs to the death for example
it doesn't make any evolutionary sense
because if she dies obviously the cubs
die
so it's not like in a human society or
even an elephant society where if the
mother was to defend her youngsters to
the death that almost let me survive
because they'd be adopted by another
female that just wouldn't happen with
the Lions yes there could be a low
suckled if there is a suckling female
within the pride but if there's no other
suckling female there die so yeah they
do defend their cubs certainly but not
to the death they defend them slightly
more for example then leopards do
leopards will be defensive of their cubs
but because they're solitary and there's
absolutely no chance at all of them ever
being able to look after their for the
youngsters being able to look after
themselves
what you find is that leopards will
unfortunately not so much abandon their
cubs but if things get really tougher
they're threatened badly the mother will
eventually run away and we certainly saw
that that horrible scene that we had of
Corolla losing a cub I'm not sure how
many of you've seen this two hyenas
which we caught on camera and was very
unpleasant indeed but gorillas did not
jump off the tree to go and try and save
her cub from the two hyenas she starved
and hissed and swatted at them but she
didn't go down and attack the hyenas and
that's totally in keeping and totally
logical from an evolutionary point of
view
and it's what made her that kind of
considered approach is what made her
such a successful leopards was made ting
gana such a successful leopard as well
you do not survive long out here as an
impulsive chance taker right everybody
another week has drawn to a close thank
you very very much for joining us on
this show your questions and comments as
always hugely appreciated obviously
we've had a spectacular time with these
little Cubs and I hope that we'll be
able to bring you a lot more of them
over the coming weeks until tomorrow
morning at o 500 Central African time I
hope that you stay safe and happy
wherever you are